Now THAT is air…
But what is THAT?
And how did it GET HERE?
WHAT'S WITH THE AIR?
Hey nose and/or mouth-breathers, Trace here
for DNews.
There's a question going around Reddit Science
right now that caught my eye: Where did Earth's
atmosphere come from?
And we started talking about it, and we weren't
sure either… "atmosphere" literally means,
"sphere of air," but "air" isn't really right
either -- because that's just what we have
on earth.
Venus and Titan have atmospheres, in that
gases permanently cover their surface; in
fact, a number of the bodies in our solar
system have atmospheres -- even the Sun.
The gases surrounding the celestial bodies
are held, suspended in space by the gravity
of their host planets, which determines a
lot about their makeup and potential to support
human life.
Our atmosphere came into being not long after
the Earth cooled 4.6 billion years ago.
As hydrogen and helium are extremely prevalent
in the universe chances are our atmosphere
contained them too, early on.
The sun is 98 percent helium and hydrogen...
However, as we were so close to the sun and
pretty hot ourselves, much of those lighter,
faster-moving elements escaped Earth's gravity.
Jupiter, Saturn and Uranus got to keep theirs
because they were so far away, and so much
more massive.
Scientists believe as radioactive elements
decayed and the Earth cooled, our remaining
elements coalesced into solids, liquids and
gases.
A 2009 paper published in the journal Science
says, at this point, the Earth was hit by
many, many comets and meteors -- bringing
water vapor, krypton, xenon and other atmospheric
materials.
Another, older, theory states it was volcanoes
that spewed water vapor into the sky.
We'll leave it up to the researchers, but
needless to say, at this point we know there
was water vapor, carbon dioxide, ammonia,
methane, and neon that they think was already
swirling over our hot crust.
And yet ANOTHER theory proposes that 4.5 billion
years ago, when the proto-earth was getting
hit by asteroids including a GIANT one that
formed the moon, the neon in our atmosphere
was BLOWN OFF and a beneficial ratio of gasses
were left behind.
From there, a secondary atmosphere began to
form from those volcanic blasts and the leftover
heat inside the planet.
Heavier elements like nitrogen split out forming
78% of our atmosphere today as well as the
carbon dioxide and water…
As the planet cooled … life began to form
and they did the rest.
2.7 billion years ago, when the first primitive
life forms began to form, they lived anaerobically,
or without air.
These extremophiles digested sulfates for
energy!
Completely ignoring the atmosphere.
Later, cyanobacteria or blue-green algae evolved
to suck in carbon dioxide and output oxygen
using photosynthesis.
These guys are still around today.
They use the energy from the sun, and carbon
dioxide to produce oxygen.
Eventually, and scientists know it happened,
but are unclear HOW, there was so much oxygen
in our air, that it poisoned organisms that
couldn't process it, causing a mass extinction.
Microorganisms that COULD burn O2 survived
as did the cyanobacteria and over millions
of years, they added enough O2 to support
the evolution of oxygen-sucking animals, which
evolved into the living animals today like
you and me.
As the planet continued to cool, the water
vapor began to rain down, dissolving the CO2
gases into it.
The oceans were formed in this way, and the
cyanobacteria spread creating more oxygen.
Oxygen is hard to find on most planets because
it tends to react with everything.
It rusts metals, it burns easily, it can make
water.
So how it got to the balance of 21-percent
that we have today is still being studied.
By final count, according to HowStuffWorks.com,
our air is "78 percent nitrogen, 21 percent
oxygen, 0.9 percent argon and 0.03 percent
carbon dioxide.
The remaining 0.07 percent consists of water
vapor, hydrogen, ozone, neon, helium, krypton
and xenon."
*breathes* and it's pretty nice.
Do you have other science questions?
Ask 'em!
We're always in the market for new topics.
You can post your questions here in the comments
or tweet them at us at-DNews!
And if you're loving the space stuff, come
join us on July 30th at 4pm Pacific for our
SpaceOut!
This month we're hosting NASA scientists who
work with the Mars rover Curiosity!
We're going to hang out for a whole hour asking
questions and digging into what they've been
doing on Mars for the last year.
RSVP with this link to join!
July 30th at 4pm Pacific Time.
Thanks for tuning in to DNews, please subscribe.
[a]